hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com
we are in round 13 of our coverage of
the 2021 candidates tournament race to
see who will face madness carlson for
the world championship and we have an
extremely important
game today round 13 white's going to be
played by alexander grishook and black's
going to be played by aneesh geary
the importance of this match is this is
a 14
round tournament so we're coming down to
the very end of it in first place in the
tournament we have ian nepomnich
and he drew today which means that anish
kirya if he wins
can go tie with yan now
yan does have the tiebreaker gishinish
they played
in round one in yon bietani so he does
have the tiebreaker so
if they go level and points at the end
of the tournament
then jan would be declared the champion
but
if anish kiri loses then the tournament
is over there's no way for him to
catch up so anish kyrie needs to at
least get a draw to
give himself a shot and if he wins well
then tomorrow is going to be
fireworks because uh then it puts a lot
of pressure on yanni can't just come out
with
a draw or a loss he pretty much
needs to think he he has to win because
anish kiri if he wins this game
is just on a roll winning pretty much
with white black doesn't really matter
so niche playing the black pieces that's
why
this match is so important so we'll go
ahead and get started with alexander
kadeshik he plays pawn to d4
knight to f6 pawn c4 and then after e6
knight f3 we see pawn to b6 so the
queen's indian defense something we
don't see
all too often and after pawn to d3
bishop to
b7 this is kind of the old main line it
it used to be
uh bishop to b7 uh but bishop to a6 is
kind of the the new line that a lot of
players like to play but bishop to b7
really trying to control these light
squares
uh it really becomes a hyper modern
approach for black meaning trying to
control the center of the board with the
minor pieces night here on f6 and the
bishop here on a b7
but really both sides trying to control
these light squares because
you're going to see from white bishop
here to g2 fan hitting the bishop to the
king side of the board castle on the
king side
and then both sides really aiming down
on these
light squares bishop down here to b4
check
bishop to d2 and then a very
curious exchange in my opinion for a
nation
you know coming into this knowing that
he needs to get a win
definitely prepared this specific line
plays pawn to
c5 and after bishop takes here on b4
pawn takes on b4 so bishop's exchange
off the board anish leaves himself
with the double pawns on the b file
don't see this all too often we'll see
how that works out for him castle on the
king side for alexander
and then we see castle on the king's
side for black as well knight to d2
pawn here to d6 queen to b3
attacking this pawn here on a b4 pawn to
a5
and then alexander decides yeah i'll go
ahead and allow you if you want to get
rid of your double pawns i'll play pawn
here to a3
does not take instead plays knight to a6
could have could have just taken here
and then pawn to a3 uh maybe pawn h6
recovery here to be one
uh double attacking his pawn here on b6
uh i think that is an approach that it
could have happened if you don't want to
have the double pawns but he seems fine
with the double pawns plays knight here
to a6
says yeah if you want to take here i
will go ahead and
take back with my knight here on
that's currently on a six so rook two
d1 centralizing the rook always want to
get your rooks into the center of the
board or if they're semi-open or open
files
right now white does not have any of
those since has has not exchanged any of
the pawns off the board
queen here to e7 knight comes back here
to e1 it's just awkwardly placed here on
uh f3 can't really go anywhere and
eventually you do
want to get your light square bishop
involved into the game
now as soon as it happens we do see an
exchange right here and then pawn to h5
so many times in chess if your opponent
moves backwards
knight here to e1 being an instance
then it's usually correct to be pretty
aggressive because they are on the back
foot and so
anish looks at this and says let's go
ahead and trade off here
on g2 and then just push forward here
with h5
we see knight to c2 pawn takes here some
exchanging going on
and then rook over here to b8 so with
that exchange
queen here on a b3 attacking this pawn
here on
b6 pawn up here to e4 just really
controlling the entire center of the
board here
from this shook and then pawn to e5
queen over here to
d3 just centralizing a little bit more
knight back to
c7 rook to b1 getting it on the
semi-open file
as we've talked about before and also
just putting pressure on this
b6 square that right now black has to
play defense with the rook here on
b8 and then over here to e6
and then rook to b5 attacking
the pawn here on d4 and the rook both
eyeing down this pawn here
on e5 black continues with rook to e8
and i really expected just pawn taking
here on e5 that's part of the reason
that rook to b5 happens here
after pawn takes rook takes here knight
two c5 attacking
the queen so maybe the the rook takes
the queen here
you see the knight come down take that
okay hey if you just want to exchange
material that's fine rook takes on eight
attacking his pawn right here
maybe king 2 f3 not as bad to get your
king involved into the game if the
queens come off the board that's the
major threat that you have
especially with the bishops gone as well
uh not as much harm on this king here so
you know on the spot white's up one pawn
in material there are
multiple you know three pawn chains so
maybe just didn't like that setup but at
the end of the day
uh after the move rook to e8 decided not
to take here instead play pawn
to h4 pawn to g6 from black
pawn here to f3 knight comes back here
to d7
knight to f1 so another one of those
spots where we see material come back
and
all of a sudden anish kiwi decides to go
ahead and attack his opponent so pawn
takes here on
d4 knight takes knight down to e5
attacking the queen queen falls back to
e2 there is an exchange right here and
then it comes up to
c6 attacking the rook rook falls
queen 2 e6 knight 2 e3
so just getting it back involved into
the game here
knight to e7 queen to d2 so i'm down
this pawn here on
d6 this is the last central pawn that
black has if white can really take this
pawn
and start to chip away it's going to be
very difficult for black to hold on to
this
setup and we see pawn to f5 i really
don't like this move at all
because after queen takes here on d6
it's a really really tough spot
and not only that but knight takes or
knight to a c6
now the pawn takes on f5 so just blowing
up
even more of the material pawn takes
here
queen takes rook takes knight takes here
on f5 and all of a sudden you look at
and you say wow
white is up a few pawns in material
how is this going to go well for black
well spoiler alert it's not going to go
well it's just too much material for
nishkiri towards the end of the game to
be giving up here
not sure if he just didn't calculate a
specific move in the variation but at
the end of the day
not very good so rook to d6
the district's definitely in the mindset
of hey let's exchange material i
am up a couple pawns in material so if
we just exchange this is going to be a
pretty easy end game
so rook 2 d6 says yeah if you want to go
ahead and take i will exchange that is a
fine trade
uh niche brings his rook back says yeah
that's not really what i'm going for
right now
rook back to d4 knight to c6
where it comes back here to d2 and then
what may be somewhat surprising i i
don't know why he would just trade
off material but just snap played rook
takes here on
d8 and then rook over here to a d5 says
yeah i'm not going
to allow you to get your rook involved
into the game usually want to bring it
to the second rank if you're black just
come down here
attack the king get behind enemy lines
start to gobble up some of these pawns
here in the in game
says yeah we're not going to have that
so there's an exchange and you can see
this is just very tough for nishikiri to
hold on to
playing one of the top players in the
world this is a pretty easy
end game and so there's some maneuvering
here knight 2 e5
knight comes up here to d6 both sides
get their kings involved into the game
but eventually it comes to a setup where
there's just no way
for black to really hold on to this and
then after knight to
c3 king here to f5
great little outpost here on e5 so you
can see starting to block off a lot of
the squares here king can't come to
e5 e6 and now f6 where it had been
retreating to
has to come back here to g6 just not
involved into the game at all
and then after pawn to g4 says let's
blow up the king side of the board
pawn to b5 but then knight to c5
les says let's exchange off the knights
uh but then there's just no stopping the
king could just gobble up all these
pawns over here
white still has a pawn advantage on the
king side as well
at the end of the day gibri recognizes
that
his dream of winning the candace
tournament to go on to face madness
crossman has fallen
he loses and that means uh that
jan is is the champion not pulmonic
is the candidate's tournament champion
he will fakes magnus carlsen
at the end of the year and if you
remember from round number one he was my
dark horse i thought he might have a
really good shot at winning the
tournament i think he's
out of all the competitors i do think he
has the best shot to beat magnus cross
and his style
um is is very
like he can get unpredictable off his
game he has a pretty good record
against magnus crossland so that matchup
is going to be extremely exciting
in november but uh this will conclude
our coverage of the canons tournament
just because
uh tomorrow i don't anticipate uh that
there's gonna be too many fireworks as
pretty much the the main standings uh
are pretty much set in stone uh yan has
won the tournament even if
uh he loses anish wins you know he does
have that tiebreaker so
hopefully enjoyed this tournament
coverage
we did half the rounds last year then we
took a year off
because of everything going on in the
world and now we have concluded
have done the last six rounds here over
the past week or so so hopefully you
guys have enjoyed
this uh and really excited about the
world championship player this year it
is going to be a good one so thanks
again and i'll see you guys
in the next video